what um what are your thoughts on a
Bitcoin and crypto III don't know how
much you you've looked into it but
what's your general thoughts there you
know I think we're in this this moment
with with crypto and decentralized
finance and the apps where it's about
usability you know we got this early
adopter based these developer base these
people were really into code and Finance
to adopt crypto and we had that massive
spike you know about a year and a half
ago but there's been the sort of trough
of disillusionment since and I think
that's because it's really difficult for
most mainstream people to use crypto you
know powered experiences or
decentralized apps they require complex
browsers and you know these really long
cryptographic keys that nobody can
remember you know stitching together all
these different tools and you know what
we really need is something that's more
like facebook login but for crypto we
need something that makes it really easy
for me to bring all of my crypto assets
all of my my identity wherever I go and
instantly log into these experiences you
know there's companies like bits key
which is trying to build this kind of
login layer and usability layer for for
the crypto in decentralized app space
and I think you know there's there's
other people who are trying to build
stuff like this to coin bases in that
space if I logged in with coin base that
kind of idea I think until that
usability arrives and until we can say
here's not only a use case for Twitter
but it's a easily usable use case that's
when you're gonna finally get the
mainstream adopting it and I think we're
gonna see prices increase again yeah
it's really interesting because if you
actually think about what's the most
user-friendly experience it's like
buying the crypto assets right so it's
getting on a coin base of Gemini
whatever actually just buying it once
you get past that very simple action
it's incredibly difficult and the
example that I always used when talking
to people is like we're still sending to
wallet addresses that look like random
strings of letters and numbers and until
that gets solved there's just an entire
population of users that I think can't
come into the space so I think that
you're generally spot-on there do you
see the large tech companies moving more
into the space obviously Facebook's got
Libra and kind of what they're doing
there what do you see kind of from the
Tec intersection here I feel like trying
to do something really big and ambitious
has been pretty well dissuaded by libras
reaction I can't imagine any company
like Google or Amazon especially anybody
with any antitrust concerns who's
already having problems who's trying to
sort out which of their other bets to
focus on that they're gonna dive into
this space it's become very clear that
regulators are not gonna allow tech
giants to do something that has the
level of power the level of scope that
would be necessary for it to be this
insane win for their businesses you know
in a lot of cases a lot of what you know
Facebook wanted to do with Libra can be
done with other type of visions of its
payment technology it's like yeah people
want to be able to do remittance easily
people want to be able to you know buy
and sell things without the same credit
card transaction for use I think those
are really smart goals for crypto but I
don't think necessarily trying to
replace the currency we currently use is
the way to do that if so it's like let
Facebook do that on the back end let me
pay real money it does the crypto
transfer in Libra on both sides and then
spits out US dollars on the other side
as well like that would be so much more
comprehensible for the regulators to to
accept then then what it's trying to do
with Libra and so I think it's not
necessary for these big tech company
used to launch things like that I think
they're much more interested in
launching their own credit cards their
own financial services that I play with
the traditional financial system because
that's where the real money is being
made because there's not the same
usability issues yeah is it almost every
one of these companies is gonna have to
go into FinTech right like they have the
advertising they've got like all the
models they currently have but it just
feels like each one of whether it's
Google it's Facebook Apple etc they're
all just slowly making progress into
this space and some of them are doing it
direct like obviously apple with the
apple cart etc is like a direct shot
into finance but even some of the other
companies trying to introduce like POS
and things like that just are they all
having to go to that space yeah I think
the the old trip was that every app
eventually becomes a messaging app and
now it's like every app eventually
becomes a finance
it's just because that's where the money
is being made when you move a ton of
money around some of it inevitably falls
off the truck and into your pocket and I
think that that's why you know that's
why the banking sector makes so much
money they've been creating a lot of
value they're just moving the money
around and somehow a bunch of it ends up
in their pockets and so I think those
for that same reason these tech
companies are gonna get into it more and
more you're already seeing interesting
plays in this space things like clear
bank which will take your your stripe
and your Facebook Ads accounts analyze
them and say hey you're worthy of a much
better priced loan than you can get from
a bank because we know you're actually
selling things and every dollar we give
you you earn three dollars back and so
they can give you these loans so I
wouldn't be surprised to see more more
businesses more tech giants getting into
that phase then things like patreon are
creating funds to sort of fund the
initial content creation set up for
creators and I think you'll see that too
you know one of the latest Y Combinator
companies is actually a loan system for
influencers where they can say hey look
at all the money that I'm making on my
on my sponsored content posts give me a
loan so that I can buy a better camera I
can hire a photographer then I'll make
even more money off my following and I
wouldn't be surprised to see people like
twitch and YouTube start to get into
that influence or financing space and
then of course you've got things like
Robin Hood that are trying to expand
into all types of lending and services
but anybody who deals with small
businesses as we've seen with square
there's an opportunity to get into that
financing space these tech giants have
tons of cash on hand they're not doing
anything with it it'd be better for them
to invest it through one of these models
and make a higher return than just
sitting on it so if you've got a ton of
cash and you've got a ton of users you
may as well turn into a finance company
yeah